you made a person out of a person it's a
kind of good dialogue you get a Jim yet
no one unintentionally laughter that
scene there in the street no they did
not
that wasn't one of the most notable I'm
John Humphrey we're gonna talk about
Will Smith and Will Smith in Gemini man
directed by Aang Lee you know so there's
some good with things in this movie
there's some bad things in this movie
but one thing for sure I was blown away
by it you could audibly hear the crowd
throughout because that they shot this
movie in a in what frame rate was this
forty eight or something like you've
heard of it more on 2120 some was insane
frame rate we saw it at the Regal
Cinemas like the laser quality
projection in RealD 3d this is some of
the best 3d in a live-action film I've
ever seen I was really like especially
in the opening scene I was like wow hey
he look like a giant hunts coming right
at you and yeah guns and everything it
was like whoa they're really like out
there it's it's kind of its kind of
scary and intimidating at first yeah
it's weird because it's the first time
you realize this is being projected so
much larger than you so that really
worked for me I can't speak for how the
frame rate will play in a non real deal
laser projection quality but I can say
that this seemed like the kind of
quality projection that you need to
fully experience this on and the way how
I like and how there are nolan films
that in order to truly grasp something
you know watch them on an IMAX screen
the same rule of thumb I think would
apply here for angley's visual approach
yeah find the best presentation you
possibly can
because it really worked like the things
to talk about for this movie I think are
the frame we rate the action scenes the
double the wills that's kind of ease
that exists within this there's a really
great piece of sci-fi action and then
there's a you know really undercooked
spy movie yeah because I'll say the the
action I don't think
is properly represented in the marketing
for this movie no they really only
majorly pull from like one or two
sequences there's action scenes in here
that are plain and simple awesome right
they are they are visually stunning you
got this sci-fi element of having two
Will Smith's fighting each other the
bike chase scene that you see ct's in
the trailer it's so much cooler there's
so much that happens that we eat that
leads into it and then when they get on
the bike this amazing tracking shot that
people like press X climbed one that's
when the shot was done yeah not the
sequence with the shot because it was
beautiful inspiring I was yeah I was
really blown away by it and it seemed
like the whole frame rate and then the
effects and everything in angley's
unique special touch was really applied
during the action moments here and then
the other thing with the other Will
Smith there were times where look
flawless yeah like there's two of them
there's a young Will Smith oh my god
they did it they did it there's a few
moments that I could think of that
especially look good can even jar well
it comes back the considerations you
take when you're shooting CGI and
there's one moment that because there
are a lot of things to think about
during this movie young Will Smith calls
older Will Smith to a specific place and
he insists on that place and part of my
my way oh yeah cuz it's dark down there
you can really make the CG look good in
it because yes some of the most
difficult to nail shots are in those
hero shots in bright daylight but a lot
of the movie is done with a very
impressive panache for lighting as well
eglee brings such a visual flair to this
and to speak to the frame rate and the
visual effects like that's hard because
you have that many more frames to
animate of a really hard to nail effect
yeah and as far as the aging technology
goes yeah it's not completely
unnoticeable there are times where it
does look rough which is still weird to
say cuz it's impressive but it really
does speak to the visual prowess and
yeah that framerate takes a second to
get used to I think but for me it
actually enhanced the action as opposed
to I think everyone's go-to is the
Hobbit where it kind of took away from
it I think it also speaks to the quality
of the stunts it made everything feel
really like they did it in camera and
they were there the thing with the
action to that I thought was cool that
my mind kind of goes to video games it's
kind of like
when you get the option in a game to
look at it from third person point of
view and then hop into first person
point of view because there's a lot of
POV shots in here in POV and there's a
great POV shot to do serve to enhance
the experience of the scenes the thing
though is is that in between all this
because there's like a plot here sure
you've seen the trailer you know you
know they see a lot and actually the
movie kind of behaves as though you
don't know what the revelations gonna be
well Will Smith is the best at what he
does how do I know this because the
movie reminds me every other scene he
says well life is the best
everyone says you're the best you're the
best wills I'm the best that's why
there's another me out there got my that
was a little distant it's torturing me
that I'm the best wanna be something
else
I think Will Smith you know he brings
some of his charisma his charm I don't
know which performance is better young
or old this feels like a script that was
probably sitting on the shelf for 20
years because there were times where
this feels like a 90s action movie
totally except without any of the fun
cheesy Flair in between the action
scenes this movie approached the idea of
cloning like you would have been maybe
the 90s my lower absolutely feel my
ghost fallen Kingdom world I don't think
it's mine the only time the frame rate
for me didn't work was actually in
between the action moments there's no
personality or visual flair at all or
rhythm or real flavor of any kind
nothing but it's shot in the most basic
way edited in the most basic what not
not saying every shot in here needs to
be like a crazy money shot it's just the
scenes are so kind of lackluster that
the frame rate was then distracting to
me because I'm like why don't you just
save the frame rate moments maybe there
might have been inconsistent but for me
personally I was kind of like maybe just
say the cool frame rate scenes for the
action moments not have to worry about
your frame rate I made it more visually
interesting scene within just dialogue
driven narrative because most of this
movies not action and most of it is plot
really on the nose expositional like
there are some major just monologue
exposition dumps in here that I'm like
this is really just going going going it
feels almost like a college script
project that got elevated
with this amazing technology because all
of the dialogue is pretty much
boilerplate spy thriller dialogue they
all talk like cool spy people they even
address each other and like the same
Cadence's with the last name first and
like aw did lessor situate this wait
it's just it all has no defining flavor
beyond the action sequence right yeah it
starts to feel dull because you can tell
where it's going it's not as
mind-blowing as it thinks it is and it
feels like two movies Frankenstein
together it feels like a really amazing
action sci-fi thriller meets like a
first draft of a treatment of a basic
spy movie and so yeah it's weird because
I think everything on a technical level
is on point for the action and I think
regardless of what the script is doing
all the actors are doing a good job
they're all committed they have
chemistry I think there's just nothing
to the script
I think Mary Elizabeth Winstead stood
out in terms of a player that wasn't
really marketed at all yeah I thought
she did a really good job it was Smith's
fine I thought he was gay like I liked
him enough by the end of it that I was
like yeah I think with the good script
was great this could have been really if
you're gonna get multiple Will Smith's I
think you really got to serve the
character a lot better that's the only
part owed in the writing where I'm like
you really should have done a better job
in comes good a thousand you had you had
plenty of time to really toy with the
way this messes with either one of their
psychologies in a really gripping way
they kind of just meet the bare minimum
and it's for them well and then Will
Smith is doing his best to really
elevate those scenes for sure he does
bring the emotional depth to it the
problem strip is resting the entirety of
the quality of the character just in
whatever a homework Will Smith and
that's true of almost every character
because there isn't anything that is
very original beyond action spy mainly
Shea's well I've owned is just as
generic as we thought he would be and
like there there are hints that in a
yeah in a movie that had more commitment
to any kind of choices with his
characters could have been interesting
to some degree but yeah he just is
another undercooked under writtens kind
of snively element of this project and
so when you have this action that is so
dazzling and also very hard-hitting and
very
real and immediate it's like you're
there and that's part of what's
impressive about it when the rest of the
movie feels like a complete movie
fantasy it really creates this
inconsistent experience I mean overall I
would still recommend it check it out if
you love action I would recommend it in
the exact format we watched it like I
said at the VA and I know how this will
look on any other format like some
people might be distracted by the
framerate and on different kind of
format but if you watch it in the format
that we watched it in it's worth it I'm
really 50/50 over it but I would still
say I'll go watch it yeah it's it's
certainly not the sum of its parts but
it has some great parts that are worth
seeing I think if you do care about
stunts action you know that aspect of
cinema there is some stuff that's really
worth seeing in a theater environment
that has enough good work around it to
support it it's just you know don't go
in expecting much because if you do I
think you'll be kind of upset you know
all right guys well what Will Smith
movie from the past would be better with
the Will Smith of today comment below
you guys can subscribe to the reel
rejects click that notification bell
thank you again RealD for hooking that
up for a wrap this up let's get a page
from the day shot to a man named Daniel
Gallagher
Daniel I was gonna say hi now that we
are friends on Facebook Daniel I wanted
to say that a snooping through your
photo you seem like an irresistible
gentleman I can only imagine you know
with the fact that here in the medical
field I'd have everyone at our patreon
page you're probably the one who is the
best access to getting himself a little
cloned Daniel with the ladies I can
imagine being like make a threat to all
the other men in the room but to
Daniel's well that's a crime spree
waiting to happen
don't do it Daniel yeah your ego will
get too big and you will hurt someone or
you'll just you know wither yourself
away trying to keep up with all those
ladies because you know two of you isn't
gonna be enough you're gonna have to
create a whole army of gal occurs to
keep up I went a lot darker
you did you did I tried to bring it back
up into the light that's all that's the
Gemini side of this man's the two sides
it's the dark and light shout outside